[Music]
here straight down
e
you're not going to be in the elow at
all all everything's right here in
the so can't and you don't want to be on
the side at all you're over here like
this and you keep turning right here
right here so I don't start
once as the angle changes I keep it
going this
way then he falls down right under
me and you're in that shoulder this
right continuously turn back towards
knee
boom
corre very small
very small boom very small not enough no
no turn
under okay try again then watch where
you're putting your your hands
so um you have to picture where's the
ful from in the wrist for this
row okay
so just like I don't want to be out here
I don't want to be on the diagonal side
cuz I'm not attacking the
elbow same thing I don't want to be up
here on by the fingers you see because
the fulum is right here it's right here
underneath the Palm heel so I am about
to slide off so you don't you don't want
to get here like that and do like that
because your palm heals what's pushing
it and that fulcrum's about here okay
okay so if you take the
metacarpal and you know you have the
wrist
joint and I want the maximum
leverage so I want to use as much of the
metacarpal as
possible obviously this would be the
most right putting my palm heel pressure
right here that's the longest the
metacarpal is do you guys see that but
you're that much closer to slipping off
you you understand you're you too much
your margin for error is too small so
when you come up here and you match the
fingers I'm right by the edge don't
match the fingers feel
instead where is a good solid base on
the metacarpal with that heel palm and
that's what I keep making go around okay
don't don't look to match the fingers
and slide up the fingers like that try
to
again just like if I if I'm doing
regular put guys I'm in that joint and
that elbow so this the second the
technique starts to come back I lock
that joint and I move his Center in
other words I'm not moving his arm
that's not what I'm doing okay so
likewise when you're on this one don't
move his arm nothing's happening then
you get that you get it so when you're
when you're here like
this that's
happening
ASAP so I'm here nothing happening
you're in the elbow you're in that hinge
no this goes
here right away
no I did at the end but not at the
beginning
okay right
away from our standard is I'm not going
here everything goes in the joint so
this hand these two hands are doing the
action that I want to
happen it's not in here going in the
elbow it's here so come
up leave your sword finger extended
middle finger
here other hand there to assist okay and
that's how it's all right here in my
body
here okay try it again okay since we're
ping then we have to have an
attach immediately from here okay this
can't be
it it's not
it CU you threw him under you
so obvious ones is just a stomp but I
have the arm and since I'm pinning I
have I push down
not around
not up not some crazy little thing here
through down I just keep pushing down
okay that'll take it into this Bend of
your
Kat that's what you want and that's what
you rip the shoulder off
with this is different maybe Chris you
could do this on
Virginia but that's a big old arm I
don't
know but I'll get that shoulder
in the joint right down pushing down
boom is the shoulder
dislocation so some things to watch
for is you want to go like
this don't it just
pushes down I'm
doing
is
down there it
is he lands in the
dislocation shape your body's doing it
so he's there and
is what you're doing just like you're
doing C Net okay you just don't show it
throw
itom down right into it
okay all right down not around not
okay uh this one he'll have a fist okay
a lot of you're still doing this kind of
stuff and you do it in the Fist and
you'll feel like ah there's not it's not
there okay so he'll have a
fist it would be similar to where he's
holding a knife or he threw a PCH or
whatever okay not that this ski but
somewhere you find it so he has the Fist
and this you have to be able to crank
this thing around and do the same
technique it should it's not any more
efforts it doesn't matter if his hands
closer if I'm in the right place
but place but it will if you're in the
wrong
place okay let's try
let's look at some
differences it's hard for you to tell
you're so used
to that okay so what's happening is
nothing till you get here you see then
you're kind of doing like a shho n
really what that is
okay so some differences is his hand
doesn't
raise another difference is he doesn't
stays perfectly still until I get
outside the
shoulder okay and then watch his elbow
which way is it
going pay attention mark it in space
watch his elbow plot it vertically East
West do the CH nag
one East or
West do it again East watch
the West do you see that so
that's happening because this hand is
bringing this this
way when you're doing your sh you're
bringing his hand that way you're
bringing this hand that way this one's
going this way you see so this hand goes
this way and this hand goes around it
you see that okay bring that in let's
try another variation you can do here is
here
so I using this hand doing the same
mechanics and this one's doing my
for and that will help you not have to
grab in place you're just
here so you're more sticky there it is
right
[Music]
keep contact you see it right
there right
there right there
[Music]
okay and you stick with whatever you get
you're just following the same
principles it's in the joint keep it in
the joint or let it go into the elbow
keep it in the wrist all right so uh if
I was going to do like a taller tie I
don't want
to do a snatch like that okay my legs
get into it my legs get into it you see
that this is this is different I'm going
to put my legs into it
okay so same thing when you're doing
this
stuff you're not here and your arms move
and then I go with it
okay this thing is
here and my
body is doing
it you see that and then the same thing
when I'm going to pin him I'm not
here is my body this is doing
it okay and it' be the same thing when I
break this my whole body all my legs and
my glutes are
moving ises that make
sense
so
here body here body
body okay got it you can do it slow like
that but it's heavy right okay try